the time that you spent exploring the
Frozen Wilderness of Iceland alongside
Bear Grylls oh yeah well one of the
highlights which is being there like
being in Iceland with Bear Grylls
everything we did being hooked up to a
harness without knowing it then being
connected to a helicopter and being
flown across Iceland hanging dangling
from a helicopter not fun part was when
they asked me what are you most afraid
of and I said like I really would love
to not do things but things that were
too high and then the last challenge was
me having to drag myself across a line
with a 1500 foot drop and I was like I
told you I was afraid of heights he's
like well like he's like we can take the
other walk around which takes seven days
and I was like what the and I was
like I told you I was afraid of heights
and and I did that that sucked your leg
was wrapped around a rope and I was
yanking myself laying on a rope across
this thing and the Rope was just flying
back and forth in the wind and there was
Bear Grylls going like you can do it
mate